-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome.
Welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't know about you guys,
but I am stuffed
with wings and nachos
from my impeachment
trial party, and --
[ Laughter, applause ]
Yeah, of course,
the big story today
is that Trump's second
impeachment trial
has finally begun.
That's right, two
impeachments are historic,
but just like Tom Brady,
Trump won't rest
until he gets to seven.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Seriously, I can't believe
we're talking about Trump again.
Even herpes knows when
to take a break once in a while.
I mean, just --
But tonight,
everybody's talking about
one of Trump's lawyers,
Bruce Castor.
He kicked off Trump's defense
and never really
got to the point.
But this is real.
Check this guy out.
-My name is Bruce Castor.
When I was growing up
in suburban Philadelphia...
Here's little Bruce --
8, 9, 10 years old --
listening to this
back in the late '60s.
We still know
what records are, right?
On the thing you put the needle
down on, and you play it.
You ever heard
Everett Dirksen's voice,
it's the most commanding,
gravelly voice.
"Gallant Men"
is the name of the --
of the, uh...
of the album.
-[ Groans ]
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Even Joe Biden was like,
"Come on, man.
Wrap it up."
If the Senate had
an orchestra pit,
they'd be playing
him off like...
♪ Neh-deh-la-dah-dee-dee-dee ♪
"Get on out of here."
Oh, gosh.
Given who his boss is,
I'm pretty sure that that was
his opening
and closing statement.
[ Imitates Trump ]
"You're fired."
[ Normal voice ]
Meanwhile, Rudy Giuliani
was watching like,
"Damn, this guy's good."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, he started talking
this afternoon
and should be done around
the fourth hour
of the "Today" show tomorrow.
Man, could that guy possibly
waste any more of our time?
[ Bottle crinkles ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitates bottle crinkling ]
A little crinkle crunch.
He -- [ Laughs ]
He crunched it out a little bit.
Alex, can we play that
one more time
just so I can hear
that water bottle crinkle?
[ Bottle crinkles softly ]
[ Bottle crinkles loudly ]
[ Laughter ]
He's having fun, man.
Come on.
Well, guys, I think
it's safe to say,
no one wants to
relive the events
of last month's insurrection,
but it has led
to some interesting flubs.
Here, I'll show you what I mean.
Listen to this.
-Donald John Trump
incited the erection --
insurrection.
-Does the President of the
United States believe
that former president Trump
incited an erect--
excuse me, incited
an insurrection?
-Who has been impeached for
inciting the erection.
-He did incite an erection
on the Capitol.
-If I have to embrace someone
who just incited an erectio--
an insurrection--
[ Laughing ]
Oh, my.
-Hey.
-Wow.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Drumsticks tapping ]
-Well, President Biden and
Vice President Harris
met with the CEOs
of Lowe's, The Gap,
Walmart, and JPMorgan
to discuss
the President's stimulus plan.
There was an awkward moment
when the CEO of Walmart
walked up to Biden and said,
"Hey, I know you.
You're one of our greeters."
[ Laughter ]
They would have invited
the CEO of Old Navy,
but they were afraid
it would lead to Biden
telling another long story.
[ Imitating Biden ]
"The Old Navy used to be
called The Boat Squad.
[ Laughter ]
It was led by Dicky Kimblewad.
He had one arm
and three nipples."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Well, last night,
there was another episode
of "The Bachelor,"
and things got pretty intense.
And the emotions on that show
can be a little hard
to handle sometimes,
so we thought we could help.
Here's a clip from the episode,
but re-voiced with the least
emotional person we know --
Siri.
This is "Let's Get Siri-ous."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Man: [ Whispers ]
Let's get Siri-ous.
-Weak bitches lie.
-You know what
a weak bitch does?
They tear down other people
to make themselves look better.
That's what you did.
Hold on.
I need to fluff my hair.
I forgot who I am for a second.
♪♪
I had a weak-bitch moment,
but I'm back.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Wow.
[ Laughing ]
Oh, she came back.
Oh, my gosh.
Hey, get this --
a pair of Nike sneakers
designed for
former president Obama
are going on sale for $25,000.
Huh.
No offense, but those look like
the perfect complement
to Obama's dad jeans.
I'm just saying.
If the Obama sneakers
are too expensive,
for 50 bucks, you can buy
a pair of SKECHERS Shape-Ups
designed for Joe Biden,
so it's up to you.
I had no idea
Nike did this for presidents.
Apparently, they made
the same sneaker for Trump
but with a built-in
ankle monitor.
It's pretty cool.
[ Audience groans ]
Interesting to see.
It's just --
[ Applause ]
Well, this is going viral.
Down in Texas, a judge was
holding a virtual hearing,
and one of the lawyers
had some trouble
with a Zoom filter.
This is real.
Check this out.
-John, I believe
you have a filter turned on
in the video settings.
-Yes, and I don't know
how to remove it.
One of our assistants
was just trying to...
I'm here live.
I'm not a cat.
-[ Laughs ] Aw.
What?
[ Laughter ]
I'm glad he cleared that up.
"I am not a cat, okay?"
The courtroom
sketch artist was like,
"Ugh, didn't think I'd be
drawing whiskers today,
but, hey, what can you do?"
Yeah, when he saw that,
Trump was like...
[ Imitates Trump ]
"I want that guy."
[ Normal voice ]
It got weird when
the filter disappeared
and the lawyer
was licking himself.
[ Laughter ]
Get this --
a company has created
a new laptop prototype
with seven screens.
Take a look at this thing.
I can't wait to be on a plane
when some guy in the
middle seat opens that up.
[ Laughs ] "You mind
if I use the armrests, dude?
[ Grunts ]
Check all my screens there.
[ Laughter ]
Gotta make sure
my Grindr's up.
The Twitter is on the --
Gotta make sure that..."
You're not that
important, buddy.
It's all good.
And, finally, after dashing
across the Australian freeway
and causing a multi-car pile-up,
a koala got comfortable
in the car of its rescuer.
Look at this guy.
Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Wow.
-See?
When your country beats COVID,
that is your top story.
You know what I'm saying?
That's what we got
to look forward -- We got that.
We have a great show
for you tonight, everybody.